Joel it's so great to see you again it's
so wonderful to talk about it's a
wonderful knife um this was such a fun
horror movie uh I do have to ask with
the film being you know an inspiration
of the Jimmy Stewart classic were you a
fan of the original was that something
you liked I've never seen it you've
never seen I know what I I don't know
what to what you are referring you no
you don't know uh no I yes no I think
it's uh Frank aa's it's one of life is
one of the greatest movies ever made and
uh uh literally and the film Noir part
when you know the whole I mean it's it's
that movie uh threads so many needles
and it's science fiction I mean on top
of everything else and so uh it's you
know it's and Jimmy Stewart is one of
the greatest movie stars of all time I
mean I mean that movie is literally
perfect and uh so why not add slashers
and why not add a you know a faceless
angel that shows up and kills people um
yeah no uh it's wonderful life I think
you know uh when you watch movies from
15 or 20 years ago they seem dated and
then when there's certain movies like
like it back to the future which my boys
watch and they thread a interesting
needle that they yeah the and that they
go doesn't seem old to us and I feel
like that way about It's a Wonderful
Life it's of course it's and in black
and white and all that but you don't
think about those things and then you
watch other movies from those that era
and you're like oh this seems uh seems
weird and I don't understand it and
anyway that's a very long answer yeah
and you know the thing about it's
wonderful life yeah it is like the
Twilight Zone um it is quite nightmarish
uh you know but it works really well
especially when you guys have adapted it
with its wonderful knife so um are you a
big fan of horror though I know you've
done horror movies before you did
Deliver Us from from Evil where you the
cop with the backwards hat like the Hat
you wore backwards everywhere yes uh my
friends refer to that movie as ghost
cops uh which was yeah deliver with the
amazing Eric Bana uh directed by the
amazing Scott derkson and um know I
really do like horror I like horror
films uh but I feel like they're kind of
like uh it's the say like when people go
like I just love a genre I love the
genre but I but if the movie is not good
then I don't like that movie uh uh but
so it's people like oh I like romantic
comedies I do too I like good ones so uh
like yeah and I'm just watching like
hereditary
is one of the best horror films ever
made and uh and then you know there's
ones that aren't scary at
all uh but yeah yeah so anyway that all
said um if the script is good and uh you
know the director's good then
I don't care what genre it
is unless it's an adult film so so but
but like so this you know I read this
script and I was like this is this is
really good and met the director and he
knows what he's doing and he and
obviously Jane wood trp is terrific and
people like Justin long are some of the
best I mean he's he's extraordinary and
Jane really carries the movie and and uh
and uh so anyway that that's a very long
way of saying I do like horror and uh I
like being in
it I'm I'm so happy that this tiny
little movie is
getting like when we made it I was like
very small little movie it was uh and uh
and you know obviously the horror
holiday genre has really come into its
own and it's been around you know for a
while and uh like Silent Night deadly
night back in the80s and and uh and now
you know now it's this is going to be a
thing this is going to be like holiday
movies it's going to be like this every
year thank God it's great yeah um you
know there are alternate realities in
the movie uh so as an actor what's that
like navigating one side of a very
loving patriarchal figure and then
flipping that on its head to what we do
see inevitably happen which I won't
spoil it's you know um I liked I I like
that stuff because it's it's a challenge
and it's twists and turns and the
director really uh was able to set the
tone he you know when when we went to
the reality the the the narish reality
um you could the lighting was all you
know everything was wonderfully adjusted
and uh it so I find that really fun
uh I I like the challenge and and uh
again like Jane is such a good actor
that uh it was easy to do and uh and
there was some really great you know
it's it's an like comedy horror holiday
and then you cuz it has to be funny and
you have to be scaring people at the
same time so it's kind of like like a
roller coaster uh I mean I know it's
such a cliche but I was like there's a
mo like roller coasters you're screaming
and laughing and having fun and then
you're like your body says you're going
to die then you don't and then you go
have then you go have a pretzel with
horrible cheese on it right yeah shees
is it's actually the the enemy of my
life I I have dairy allergy which I will
talk to you about later but um I would
love to hear that on my podcast about
lactose intolerance it's not even
lactose intolerance it's literally just
a dairy allergy like I can't have cheese
milk yogurt any of it it's very if you
were if you were to
have I'm just trying to think like if is
it like a peanut allergy where if
there's milk product in something yeah I
will have a reaction to it yeah it's
been very hard to eat out
lately did this develop this developed
in the last couple of years yeah I don't
know if people want to hear about my
issues if you were to like CU my wife
was allergic to like fur like so dogs
that weren't didn't like a poodle she
was fine with but like a golden
retriever she couldn't do but I came
home with a Pug oh and uh it which sheds
everywhere but and then she was like she
reacted for like two weeks and then it
got better so
I'm saying maybe just a huge slice of
Brie once a
day I'll have to tell you what it's like
but it's a it's a terrible sort of
allergy it's weird but um yeah you a lot
of a lot of Japanese food for you then I
guess yes for sure um you know getting
to the movie getting back I don't want
to spoil it but there are a lot of like
physical action type scenes that you're
involved in um do you do your own stun
when it comes to these kinds of moments
because I feel like you are physically
in there and also you can always always
tell there's a very tall person I'm like
it has to be you well yeah I mean they
the uh the I most of the time I do it
and um unless they're like what are you
an idiot you got to let a stunt man do
this uh and like I wouldn't you know I
they weren't too in I like on community
and whatever I always wanted to do them
and because they were so much fun um but
yeah I mean I like when Tom Cruz jumped
across that building and just shattered
his ankle I'm like oh yeah that's why
you have stuntman do that but you know
whatever he's you know Tom Cruz but uh
he's he's a he's a superstar but um no I
love that stuff that the the world of
making
movies uh is uh I love it so I cannot
believe I get to work in the the that
that I can't believe I get to there's a
really good movie called Gods and
Monsters about uh with the Bren and
Frasier and Ian mlen it's about it's
really really really great and it's the
that's why I mean it's a lot of work and
I but I love the work yeah no you're
great at it too and Ela you're a very
likable person you have a magnetic
chemistry with everyone um you when when
working with Jane what was it like
bonding behind the scenes to what we
actually get to see on film because it
trans well well there was one we were
shooting in this house and there was
just this one room in the house that we
all sat in and chatted to each other and
you know there's a lot I mean there's so
we her mom was there the whole time who
she's a delight uh and Jane is really
funny and uh so it was yeah it was just
you know as far as bonning it was just
like shooting the each day and then
then we went back to the the motor in
and some of you know if if people were
awake and and she also had the Lion
Share of lines and had to handle all
these scenes so uh she's um so so she
had you know she was extremely busy and
so and I you know don't wouldn't hey you
want to go out and and uh have a couple
beers and just hang out no I'm the star
of a movie I gotta do so um yeah
and her mom was again a delight and uh
yeah I I was thinking about like being
because I didn't really get into the
business till I was in my early 30s and
you know she's like 20 and I was like oh
I would have been a I don't know what I
would have been like if I was that young
with that much responsibility but yeah
she she can handle it and uh does
swimmingly yeah how old were you when
you did Bill and N I just remembered
that when you were doing the People's
Court was really oh my gosh that is the
fact that you even know that I had I had
all Bill n episodes on tape so it's
funny that I actually remember that you
were on that episode that's amazing I
would have been
25 wow okay baby baby
24 yeah right around in there um I was
on a show called Almost live in Seattle
and and uh it yeah they going way back
that is that that before you were born
and uh uh so that yeah I got on that
show when in
90 uh four 95 and uh yeah that that was
a locally produced sketch comedy show
that aired on Comedy Central and yeah it
was on an NBC affiliate but locally
produced so it uh it was it was an an
anomaly and uh I learned how to of relax
on camera a bit a bit a while you've
done great though um you know with this
movie I think you guys you really
captured what like a Bedford fall sort
of town looks like um so you guys shot
this in Vancouver right was this like a
summer shoot or winter shoot like what
was that like yeah shot it in uh
February
March uh February and it was um yeah
which I can't remember the town it was
about an hour outside of Vancouver and
it looked very much like you know
Mayberry and uh yeah Bedford Falls and
um yeah it was uh
freezing all the time and it snowed a
bit uh and the good news about shooting
in uh you know in British Columbia is
that if you need a night shoot the night
you know the sun goes down at four or
3:30 and doesn't come up until 8 in the
morning so you can go you can go forever
yeah that's can you know you're part
Canadian you know what it's like the
weather I am look at this you can see no
and I I whenever someone says it shs of
Vancouver I get excited because it's I
love it up there and the food is really
good and the people are great my mom's
she's she's full Canadian so uh I love
it up there and I love how and I think
it was Chris Carter of xfiles the
Creator who made you br that look the
trees and the the wall water and the
mist and the mountains made that a
character and I thought that was yeah so
I think there was some like with this
movie they you know it obviously cap
captured a small town America field uh
and uh but that's our director who was
great and uh the same way that the movie
First Blood with uh Sylvester
Stallone uh where they they were like
what town is that is that an Oregon no
that was uh I think was shot outside of
BC yeah I think so too um I should know
more Canadian trivia I really should but
you know uh this movie is so much fun
and I can't wait for audience to watch
it on shudder on AMC plus this holiday I
do want to add though uh I this is not
the only Christmas movie you've done in
the a lot of movies that people will be
watching this season there's also merry
freaking Christmas which you did almost
a decade ago now and I would just like
to talk a little bit about it because it
is another Christmas movie it is a great
movie uh what was it like working with
Robin Williams uh it they say uh don't
ever meet your Heroes because you'll be
disappointed and I could not disagree
more with that because he was a hero of
mine and uh continues to be and it he
was everything I could have ever hoped
for and he was just lovely and uh when
he died I was uh I sat on a bench and
cried and uh I missed he is just he was
just
exactly what I mean I couldn't he was
just so wonderful and um his heart was
so big and he that was like oh this is
why he's such a superstar because he
wears his heart his heart fills up the
screen and so yeah and we just saw I
don't know how I don't think the movie's
the greatest movie of all time but it's
uh but just getting to spend time with
him and then I saw Lauren Graham last
night and uh who we we I mean that it
was such a wonderful little time to to
do a movie and uh yeah we talked about
that she's lovely and so um anyway that
yes I can't yes I guess this would be my
second Christmas movie I haven't I
haven't thought about that wow good good
uh good that's I yeah yeah I think you
might have be 10 people that have seen
that movie yeah well my sister so it's
11 um well L something you loved about
him though as a scene partner that also
might have helped elevate your
performance in a way that you couldn't
have without him there's a scene where
he and I are in the truck having a
pretty big heart-to-heart sonto father
talk and I remember like we're supposed
to be kind of pretty emotional and I was
like I I I don't know how to do this uh
really I'm not sure if I'm going to do
get there or how this is going to work I
was kind of nervous and it's Robin
Williams and then uh just I was just
like just listen to him and uh do the
lines and listen to him and then that
yeah and then we got there and I was
like I can't believe this is happening
and we did it over and over again and
and uh it was just a lovely lovely and
he T yeah he T he so he I saw him just
kind of like oh he just has this direct
line from his brain to his mouth to his
heart and that's yeah that really just I
was like oh I it kind of opened up up
side of me I was like oh right this is
It's just sitting there for uh for us so
uh it was yeah it was just
uh it was like a secret little planet
then we got to be on it and uh boy I I
miss uh he's just so great and um I'm
friends with his daughter Zelda to this
day and she's lovely and her his her her
sons are lovely so yeah I'm
sad he's gone yeah you know full circle
moment though for that um Moran Mindy
was actually one of the first sitcoms to
Ever parody its Wonderful Life uh
because before that the movie didn't
have a lot of Licensing so I think it's
really fun that it kind of went around
that you just kind of how the hell did
you know that because it was in a
podcast I listened to called George
Bailey was never born so podcasts are
great they're very helpful they give you
a lot of information how did you even
know that podcast existed it's a miracle
you need to run a you need to run a
studio good for you oh yeah I would be
great at it wouldn't I um you know
before I do let you go it is the season
of giving and now that the strike is
over uh I think it's important that you
give us an update about the community
movie oh yes we we just shot it we just
got it done we shot it shot it yesterday
great uh yeah it only took a few hours I
couldn't believe it um it's going to be
amazing well you know the we we were
shooting it last summer as a and then so
I I think if as long as we can start
getting all these schedules together um
that it will probably be next summer uh
I mean that is what I am that's what I
hope for and
uh you know it's everything we're re
we're thing we everyone's in and we've
signed the thing I mean everyone's so uh
so yeah we just need to make the time
and uh once I'm shooting animal control
and crime scene kitchen and once that's
done then I then hopefully they great so
more animals more cake we're going to be
able to see more cake more animals more
cake shaped as animals but no cake eaten
by animals because that Sugar it's not
it's no good not good um animal controls
that that's coming back in Mar uh yeah
no it's coming back in March we're shoot
we're starting shooting next week um in
Vancouver and uh very excited very
excited and we're we uh they picked us
up for two seasons so bless you
fox uh and uh and then we'll shoot crime
scene in between those Seasons which
will and um so I'm yeah I very yeah I'm
thrilled I love the cast and I think you
know I love the I I freaking love
animals so it all works out it does work
out well Joel thank thank you so much
for your time uh it's a wonderful knife
will be available on shutter on AMC plus
and everywhere you rent movies on
December 1st so happy holidays to you
and your family thank you for having me
again of course
you